every month
welcome to the policy and Regulatory
committee for June
one two three four so we have our Quorum
present today
um and and just before we start
counselor Reed may find it necessary to
leave us briefly
via a phone call if need be
um in which case we'll take a brief
adjournment because it'll take us down
below the quorum
so we'll get started are there any
apologies for today please
so we've got councilors MacDonald
uh Richard McDonnell and um
who was the other
Richard mcvale thank you
uh can I have a move that they'd be
accepted please
so that's councilor Dixon councilman
McKenzie second thank you
first item in the agenda is the
regulatory Services report
I trust that everyone has read their
report that's on pages one to three are
there any questions of the author Mrs
Shepherd
cancel addiction
thank you Mr chair
um just regarding the litter
I see that we've got quite a large
amount of litter being dumped which is a
little bit of a concern does Francis see
that as growing or
how can we mitigate that
and and as part of the same question I
guess so far this year to the end of
June there's been 39 complaints in the
year it compares to 27 last year 42 the
year before and 29 the year before so it
seems to go up and down
foreign
so there's all sorts of things that come
out
that gets listed as litter they
fluctuate they go up and down a little
bit like abandoned vehicles sometimes an
abandoned vehicle will be reported but
it's somebody who's parked a car outside
a house for three days um
so it's pretty hard to gauge but
like yeah
it's
not no no sometimes we have nothing and
then sometimes we might get three in a
day and we'll get nothing for six weeks
eight weeks 10 weeks it's varied but I
don't see a significant increase at this
point
thank you
I know too that the number of
um
seizures for noise control it seems to
be very low this year compared to other
years as that person related or just
less you know the way the team's working
or just less complaints
um I think it's less complaints and
there's also there definitely is less
complaints and I think the economic
climate and money has a lot to do with
it people don't appear to be
partying like they were but now that
we've said that it's Murphy's Law will
probably
increase even our contractor has noted
that there's been a significant decrease
in the number of calls that they're
receiving
thank you any other questions comment
Council McKenzie
Francis just wondering what happens with
abandoned vehicles Etc the investigation
is to
try and track down who the owners are
just wondering what the processes are
there
so we will do a registration check and
that will give us the owner's details we
will try and find a phone number we will
ring them
sometimes we get one we had one just a
week a week or so ago that had no plates
no nothing
completely trashed just dumped on the
side of the road um unfortunately
there's the odd one that we do have to
just pick up and remove but where we can
we do track them down and um
get them shifted by the owners
thank you
any other feedback counselor
Dixon
thank you Mr chair I was just wondering
um just discussing stock in poultry
there has been a few people have
commented to me about people keeping
more hens on their property at present
because a shortage of eggs
um
do we see any has there been many
complaints
regarding hint
no roosters occasionally but there
definitely has been an increase in
people keeping hands but the bylaw
allows you to keep up to 10 here to
poultry without a permit but we do if we
get any complaints our animal team goes
and as we chat to them and we just work
with them so but there hasn't been a
significant increase in complaints
thank you Francis
any other queries I'll move that the
information be received can I have a
second a place that will need to come
from a committing member who
uh Council Laurie thank you but too well
uh welcome you uh councilor Stringer to
this meeting
yes fine thank you right I item two was
the report on the building control
activities that goes into a fair bit of
detail so Tom Pages four to ten of the
agenda are there any questions that
arise from that
well they're looking at it uh Russell
Patterson's the author
um so with with the bewaf audit
there's some uncertainty over what is
legally required it's it's someone
somewhere you're going to get some
clarification
I'm through you Mr chairman
um I think it's now case in point with
the recent loafers Lodge
um episode that happened to Wellington a
tragic event
um now NBA more and more getting more
forceful with their guidance even though
it is guidance it is deemed to be
the the the the Heritage that you're
supposed to follow now it's not
specifically in the building act that
you must go and do audits however one of
the sections under Section 111 which
I've got on there their intention is
that Tas will conduct take all
reasonable steps and that's what they
consider as all reasonable steps that
rather than just receive the annual
building we're under fitnesses that that
the owners are deemed to supply the
council and we do a desktop check of it
we are now deemed to go out and do a
percentage per a year especially of the
high risk buildings
so is it necessary to have a fee
associated with those how do we recover
costs yes we already have a fee in the
fee schedule it was built in about two
to three years ago but we haven't
actively been doing audits although we
did do 70 audits in the 2021 year when
we had a previous compliance officer and
now we're up to speed again with our new
compliance officer we're going to start
rolling them out
and they'll be invoice for them the
annual certificates that comes in who
prepares those
um they're normally prepared by an iqp
company which is an independently
qualified person company on behalf of
the owners it's the owner's
responsibility to supply the annual
building building or under Fitness but
they generally delegate that to a um to
a company to do that on their behalf so
is what the crown saying that they don't
necessarily accept the quality of what
these people are submitting I think what
they're saying is that they want
councils to go out and do an audit that
the iqps are actually doing the job when
they go on the site we've had recent
cases in Gore where iqps have been found
they haven't been doing their job
correctly and there's been a couple
issues being exposed when the iqp
company changed recently
so we're following up on those to get
them correct any other questions Council
Reed
thank you Mr chair just for
clarification for the public I presume
uh bewaf is a building warrant of
Fitness yeah thank you I'm also just on
that point it's good to see that the
consents are pretty much within the time
frames that they're supposed to be
so always positive for the tradies
um through the chair yes consents we're
getting back to time frames are getting
better the peak has certainly gone in
actual fact the um if you saw our um
chart at the moment you would see for
June the consents on the door is
actually plummeted so we've seen in June
we're thinking it's going to be a
short-term thing but we're just not not
100 sure
um so we had a Peak in May of what was
issued now we've got a
a decline
councilor Stringer
three Mr chair
um do we have any numbers of consents
that have lapsed
sorry
um through the chair no we probably
don't have that as a as a figure there
but we can find that out
um
all right over what sort of period he is
looking
I think they're issued for a year so
over that year period of up outside that
year period like what ones haven't been
acting upon because obviously you're
going around doing your code of
compliance on the on the um
on the certificate or consent
to say that it's been done that's what
ones haven't followed through and done
the work and have just let it lips sure
there's just to clarify that this
elapsing is actually work that doesn't
start within 12 months in the end if it
gets to the 24 months period and the
work's not completed it's at that point
that we refuse to issues The Code
Compliance certificate so that's the
difference between that and the lapsing
but yeah
okay
that we can find it any other questions
how how many temporary accommodation
providers do we have other than motels
sorry Mr chair we did a we did a group
check last week and come up with 29 in
total 29 buildings that we feel would
have
um some sort of accommodation now that's
talking likes of Saint Peter's hostel
motels Croydon Lodge
um you know Backpackers Flats those sort
of things that are that are more than
just residential accommodation so we
come up with a figure of 29 buildings
and that's probably
quite High there might be a couple of
weed out of there so does that include
the people provided accommodation
through the different websites that are
available
no no no that's nothing to do with
Airbnb or anything like that because
they
potentially aren't an accommodation
provider under the building act until
they go through a change of use
in in your report you also referred to
um uh the file destruction option
and and highlighted some things that
that might need to be done are you
wanting some feedback from the committee
on that
um three years Mr chair um I really just
highlighted that because
um I think Council as a whole has been a
little bit reluctant to
to destroy hard copy files they've been
squirreled away stored in Auckland I
believe still by the company that
scanned the had the files initially and
[Music]
without any formal
um
or just say it process
I believe our it people have been going
through the process and it's got to go
to archives New Zealand to get formal
approval to to destruct any hard copy
files
so that's between chief executive and it
to progress that and then headed on to
Heritage New Zealand right so there's
nothing required no I don't know
all right any other questions so can I
have a mover the report be accepted
please counselor read second uh Clan
seller Dixon thank you item three pages
11 to 23 is the housing and business
capacity report
which
um Katrina is the author and
um so what what you've described is that
there's a statutory requirement to
prepare a report and leave it to the
district plan review is that a fair
summary
uh yes though the requirement to provide
this report is annually so it won't
always align with the district plan
review but at this point of time the
district plan review will create the
additional capacity required to meet
Gore districts demand requirements
capacity requirements so do we have any
questions in terms of what's in the
report please it contains a fair bit of
data and other stuff that I guess will
be feed will feed into the long-term
plan process so from that point of view
it's very useful thank you
councilor Dixon sorry
thank you Mr
just in terms of rental affordability I
see the rental affordability for Gore is
really
dropped well back compared with the rest
of New Zealand is that
regards to financial hardship maybe or
The Roots have risen dramatically in
this District
um that's just due to the price of rents
as the data that we're capturing to put
in this report as opposed to the reasons
why they've increased
statistics are not looking particularly
good are they really for Gore rental
accommodation yeah correct it's showing
that there's an affordability issue or
the um the affordability of rentals is
getting worse yes thank you Katrina
the report also refers to a need for
social housing does that take into
account the um project that's underway
in e-score is that just a short-term fix
um are you talking about the clang Aura
project so this data is based on who is
registered with the ministry and also
can sense that are issued so because
that resource consent application is
lodged but not issued it hasn't been
taken into account in terms of houses
provided
okay any any other questions arising
from that report if not can I have a
mover that would be accepted please
counselor Dixon second third I'll second
it thank you
uh report number four District plan
notification in section 32 report which
is on page 24.
um which is one of those technical steps
as part of the district plan review do
you want to just simplify it for us
please Katrina
yes sure so
um with District Plan reviews you're
essentially looking at the Effectiveness
and efficiency of your current District
plan looking at what other issues and
options are out there and are working
out what your needs of the district are
and updating the plan accordingly in the
background behind that is what's called
the section 32 reports which is section
32 of the resource management act and
those are kind of the BP planning
technical reports that have all the cost
benefit analysis what the issues and
options are why you've landed on certain
options what technical input you got
what community and stakeholder feedback
you got what monofino feedback you got
Etc so it's kind of the report just
capturing everything in terms of the
technical analysis behind the provisions
so we've already gone to the district
plan subcommittee numerous times where
we've talked about the various issues
and options and outcomes so this is the
yeah
the report that will sit behind all of
those
outcomes
so your suggestion is that from an
efficiency point of view that I have
that delegation to
um sign that off prior to final approval
by Council yes that was discussed at the
previous District plan subcommittee
report and I think there was a
willingness to that because this is
going to be about a thousand pages of
technical planning information and it
might be more efficient for one person
to be across it
councilors won't be let off the hook
however it will appear on the council
Hub and you will have an opportunity of
reading it as much as you like but as
Katrina highlighted it as a a technical
report and I'm in a position it's not
necessarily a quality well it is in part
quality control but it's really to make
sure all the boxes have been ticked it's
not signing off saying hey um that's
that's good that's not good so it's a
process that submitters will have an
opportunity of commenting on it as well
so the hearing committee when it's set
up will have the task of going through
the report again
or 1 000 Pages you say any questions
from the committee
Council uh there's only one of you today
Dennis Dixon
thank you Mr chair
um are there any legal or insurance
requirements around your appointment
because what concerns me a little is
that you were involved in the district
plan in the early stages before handing
over to Property Group as the perceived
or real perceptions of conflict there
no there isn't and and it's an issue
that came up in my commissioner
re-certification and and I guess I
haven't reported back to the committee
but after roughly 80 hours of doing
assignments and and a one day
teams meeting I've now been re-certified
as a hearing commissioner for the next
five years with the chair in endorsement
and one of the issues that came up as
part of that process was people in the
situation I've been in and similarly for
counselors who are involved in the
preparation of the plan
requires one set of considerations when
you're preparing a plan and another step
when you're actually sitting there as a
commissioner considering submissions and
in this case looking at the section 32
report so I guess in in the case of the
section 32 reporter choosing my
knowledge and skill set to streamline
the process as it were rather than
having to go through a series of reports
that look at it in far more detail so it
is time and cost efficient to do it that
way
any other questions
all right can I have a mover that both
the report be received and that the
review and authorization the release of
the section 32 reports
um be delegated to Keith hovel
councilor read seconded by councilor
Dixon all those in favor say aye
against carried
leads us on to item five which is the
resource consent update lots of numbers
lots of reporting things are proceeding
on time are there any questions that
arise from that Tom Pages 25 to 30 of
the agenda
councilor Reed thank you Mr chair just
once again good result with those
consents but query
um building coverage breach for the
uninitiated is that
too close to the boundary or could you
um that way somebody oh sorry
it's been a long day
um could you just give me some
indication of how that actually works
please yes sure so a building coverage
breach is
um so depending on the Zone there's
certain roles about the total building
size or percentage of the site you're
allowed to build over
um I just want to find the exact consent
reference that you're referring to here
oh yeah
oh yeah so um I don't have that full
concern in front of me but essentially
um somebody might be allowed to build
say like 200 meters squared and they
might have built 250 meters squid on
this site so there's an assessment where
you consider your neighbors amenity
stormwater fix those sort of factors
that might be issues that result from
that increased coverage
any other questions
councilor McKenzie just on a similar
vein could that also be being building
slightly in the wrong location too close
to a boundary or something like that
so that would be referenced as a setback
breach
previously
we talked about having copies of the
consents and the decisions available on
the council's website how's that
progressing
um yeah sure I remember that being
raised what we're planning to do is have
consents go on the website for any
consents that are lodged in the new
Financial year been from first to July
so we'll have a process kick in from
then and then because it's a bit of a
manual process
um due to not having software there
automatically populates into a public
porthole here but we can get every
consent decision online
um so starting from consent issued from
the first of July right so members of
the public wanting to know what's in the
consent or be able to go online and have
a look and see what the decision is as
well thank you any other questions
so I'll move to the report be received
sorry counselor Reed
um just a question once again
um and just because I really don't know
the answer to this and somebody asked me
when Waka kotohi have that building site
in e-score they have to go through the
normal consent processes at Gore
District Council
or because there are
a government department does that
preclude any of that
um so it depends so while kakatahi
what's called a requiring Authority and
student like Gore District council's
requiring Authority as well there's
certain government departments councils
and infrastructure providers that can go
through a process of getting a
designation and then if you're doing any
works in your designation you don't have
to abide by the district plan rules but
you have to abide by the conditions of
your designation and you come in for
what's called an outline plan of work so
you still tell the council what you're
doing and get an approval for that
so it depends on if the site's
designated or not but the state highway
Network tends to be designated and go
through that process
it's through the chair for my head I'm
not sure whether your question was
regarding building consents as well
because Kia Ora or wakakatahi have their
own building Control Authority called
consentium and we're not yet aware
whether consenting we're going to be
doing the building can sense of the site
or whether we're going to see the
building consent applications we've
asked several times we're not getting
the straight answer so
thank you Russell um actually that's
possibly the question that was posed to
me along those lines of you know how
does it work and when they're building
an air District but um
right are we out of questions this time
so can I have a mover in a second I
think a mover please
councilor Dixon and I'll second it just
to spread it around that the report be
accepted all those in favor say aye
against carried
takes us on to report number six which
is on pages 31 to 37 from Morgan
looking at the list of policies that
that he's looking at and and setting out
some priorities there in the report are
there any questions of Morgan
councilor Reed
thank you Mr chair I see that the
election signs review policy is in
December of this year after the general
election
can we bump it to the top of the list if
I may help Council has previously
indicated that their policy will be in a
balance so that um uh the um it won't
apply to the national elections this
year and and the reason for that is and
it's dealt with the Morgan's report he
says
um the route the policy states that it
will be reviewed after each election and
the ones that we had last year was the
first election to be held since the
policy came into
um into effect so now is the time for
the first looking at it however
the the issue that really arises is do
we need the policy
given that there was non-compliance that
I observed and and then
um
Francis will be able to highlight
whether there are any complaints
received
um
I noticed some non-compliance of of the
signs I also noted that the strict
requirements of the size in the rural
area requires huge signs yet there's a
welcome sign to Gore as you come into
Gore that doesn't comply with the
lettering size but it's perfectly
readable
so what that pointed to me was that the
requirements that we've got in the
policy are probably over the top
um and so there's a couple of questions
that need to be looked at as part of any
review do we need the policy what should
be in the policy how does it compare to
what's in the district plan because
there's some rules in the district plan
and in the proposed plan and do we need
a bylaw so rather than coming back with
a straight let's update the policy I
think there's another process that we
need to go through first I don't know if
you want to comment on that at all
Morgan
through the chair I I couldn't eat
anything more
yeah so we did it as a policy first up
um just to try to see how how wington
need to go back from first principles
rather than bring it in December any
other questions coming up in that report
yes Council McKenzie
just
just it's pretty much a comment I was
approached by a political party person
last election
um and they said do you have certain
areas that are set aside for said
notices and I knew nothing at the time
well I still know nothing but um
they thought they because they did come
into Council they told me this folk and
they thought they had permission to put
signs up but when they put them up they
had to take them down again
because maybe it wasn't made clear that
they were going to be political signs I
really don't know but my main question
is do we actually have certain areas
that have set aside for those signs
especially at election time are any of
the staff able to comment before I give
my six months worth all right like many
councils have areas where election signs
are allowed to be set up and it'll be
some green spaces somewhere it'll be
Corners where all the signs can be put
together the gore District doesn't have
that and I think as part of the
consideration moving forward it's
something that we need to think about
there were some
signs that were put up at the Nash last
um
national elections and the senior
planner at the time took steps to have
them removed as my memory of what
happened
um there was also also need to be aware
that this National legislation that
applies to the national elections
um so it's the electioneering something
or another that sets out the size of
signs
um and the details that go on them but
it does have a rider saying that if
there's requirements in the council's
district plan then that applies
now the only requirements that I can see
in the proposed District plan
um
probably need to be a little tweaked and
I'll come back to the Consultants on
that
so any other comment arising from that
part of the science councilor Dixon
thank you Mr chair just observing that
there is nowhere and go that people can
actually Place their signs on any
reserve or any area I think it would be
quite wise to look at that as well yes
to get everyone a fair opportunity
now the other the other item is in your
paragraph 3.3
um you
um
referred to the financial contributions
and Industrial and Commercial
development contributions disbursement
policies
now at the previous meeting of assets
and infrastructure there was a report
put up in relation to that from our
planning Consultants
where the recommendation was that we
proceed with a development contribution
policy and that would be dealt with as
part of the long-term plan but the
consideration of the drafts and working
through the issues will come to this
committee
so while it's one that's going to end up
on the list of things to be done the
Consultants will be working on it as the
good news from your point of view
the other one I guess is 3.9 the
roading stopping policy
um
I can't recall where it comes up at the
end that policy actually makes reference
to what's in the current District plan
so just to note for your info that they
don't need to be looked at
so are there any other questions
comments Etc coming up from that report
uh councilor Dixon
adding 3
grants policy
having the ltp and the annual plan in
mind
um and our rates
protected rate rise
and seeing that we have a very high
Community grants program which is quite
a lot higher than other councils I think
it is
a good opportunity to have a closer look
at this
I know 452 000 which is very generous
and I know it does a lot of community
good but in comparison waitaki District
Council has only 75 000 in their
Community Grant so
I think it is something that needs to be
looked at maybe by the community
wellbeing committee and given that two
percent of the annual rates paid by
people I would agree with you
so does that require a recommendation
from this committee
I think that would be wise that we that
we do
I see that it's going to be reviewed in
October
maybe it could be reviewed
um
before that
how often are the community grants done
sorry how often do the grants take place
is it done as an annual event well we
haven't actually reviewed it in the last
year but the complain of the grant when
does that annually I believe it's
annually and haven't we just done it
through the chair that will go through
as part of the annual plan in terms of
the
um the grants through there but that I
think this is an opportunity for the
policy to be developed uh alongside the
long-term plan process I don't think the
needs the policy needs to be 100 in
place for you to look at
um Community grants and the interim and
what the approach may be through your
long-term plan process
so I guess what you're saying is the
policy is the process
the detail of who gets what is an annual
plan long-term plan
excellent councilor Stringer
uh thank you Mr chair um I believe we've
had discussion in the ltp sessions about
setting a budget on grants
so I think that would be part of the
process as well
councilor Reed I also note that one or
two organizations already have decided
that they don't require
their grants from Council some of them
have been have received very generous
government grants through the covert
period which seems to be Tiding them
over and I know of at least one of them
who's come back to council and said they
no longer require air ground which I
think is a really um
very admirable situation
so councilor Dixon in terms of the
community grants policy is currently set
down them for consideration in October
um what outcome do you want at this
stage
thank you Mr chair I think at this stage
since we're looking at in October which
isn't too far in the distant future and
it is part of the long-term plan
um and most of them have probably been
most of the grants have probably been
paid out just
this term I think October
for a review of that is is fine
thank you
the dust suppression policy
seems to be quite
um
prescriptive
in that it refers to council paying half
it has a dollar amount in there and says
100 meters shall be sealed
and I would have thought in the case of
some houses 30 meters might be enough
so I guess as part of the review there's
a need to look at the rationale behind
it what the effect is and its amenity as
well as health type issues from dust
um so just just it is an observation
right any other questions and comments
so we have a a recommendation that's on
page 37 uh that the report be received
and the council note and endorse the
following order of priority and and the
policies are setting up there uh can I
have a move of those recommendations
please councilor Reed a second uh
Council McKenzie thank you
and all those in favor say aye against
carried thank you
item seven dangerous and Oran sanitary
buildings policy review
how and and Russell Patterson is the
author of that how significant oh sorry
that it comes it flows between the two
of you I hope
um how significant is this policy in
Gore is it an issue
three Mr chair
um as you'll note in the report there
are six buildings uh with Heritage grade
one or two listing from that you can
infer that perhaps the policy isn't as
important as others for instance perhaps
the community grants policy
um but there are two things to note here
one uh those buildings form a
significant or some of them form a
significant component of Gore's Regional
identity uh one such building is the
Sergeant Dan building uh which if memory
serves won the hokanui uh hokanui sorry
I'm still thinking with gold
um radio hokanui
um a Facebook Poll for most iconic
landmark and Gore
and the second one is that it is
legislated by law that the dangerous and
incentral will Dent there be and
dangerous indoor and sanitary buildings
policy and that it deals to
um how the policy applies to Heritage
buildings
so the key part of watching your
reporters that are present and the
policy doesn't apply to Heritage
buildings a simple two-page policy are
there any questions or comments that
from the committee please councilor
McKenzie
just talking about that particular
building
that chimney
it affects a couple of people in this
room how is it monitored for safety
thank you
[Music]
sorry you Mr chair at current
um they've been asked to supply a
um Engineers report for that building
which includes the chimney and I don't
think we have one supplied yet
um so that is in the process at the
moment
but when you say monitoring
there's no formal monitoring by us and
until we get a complaint otherwise to
say that one of your buildings
underneath there could be classed as a
dangerous building because of what's
above you
so that's where the dangerous building
policy clicks into place
any other councilor read
um just a little bit of clarification
around that Russell does that
um because of that chimney fell
um it would block the access for
emergency vehicles in the case of
earthquakes
would that be another issue
um through Mr chair I don't think that
would be the case for that building it's
more likely endangering the occupants of
buildings directly in its path
more so than falling out of the street
I have had it said that from people with
First Responders that that would be an
issue for them was if the streets were
blocked in case of an earthquake
yes potentially there are there are
other routes though there are other
routes he could get around if that
street for example was blocked but yeah
right so would that preclude
well if that's the case if there are
other routes does that mean that
um
how does that affect the earthquake
standard
well all of those buildings within that
Precinct are part of the priority
buildings area which we have maps for
the gore and Matera that come in front
of council about three years ago for the
priority areas all of those ones have
been mapped now and either sent letters
and we've had earthquake reports for
them or earthquake reports due for those
buildings in that area
I think all building owners would have
received a letter by now to furnish a
report
so obviously they're called a priority
error because
they're within that landscape within
Gore material that can be accessed by
not only vehicle traffic but foot
traffic
um so that's that's where it comes down
to that whole priority area and then
once they're done it goes out to The
Wider wider landscape of any other
building that's possibly earthquake
prone
cancel a Stringer
ah through you Mr chair to Russell um
yes you wear my business sits right
underneath said chimney
um
and I know the building Ironman is well
below the uh 20 NBS
um
now what I'm just wanting to clarify is
with this dangerous
buildings what takes precedence
dangerous buildings or does the Heritage
list and take presents because in some
of these cases
the the costs like I know I know the
cost that's going to take Brandy
building on and up to code and it's
literally walk away what takes
precedence because eventually if we walk
away we've spent money doing this
building up to extend where we can work
we walk away where does that leave
because then it becomes derelict or it's
going to run down further and we're into
a sort of cycle
through the chair I'm not sure where
they can answer
um because ideally at the moment we
don't have any Heritage included in here
dangerous and sanitary policy however
when it is included and endorsed I'm not
just sure what the preference is
um
I can't I can't answer that and
um black and white sorry can't celebrate
sorry um
sorry about
the conflict of interest
that we're discussing
um although if we did it in general
terms then it wouldn't be I think the
question in terms of where does the
priority lie in terms of the building
ACT versus The Heritage values and and
and that is the predicament that hearing
Commissioners find themselves and when
there is a request to demolish your
heritage building and and the key
argument put forward is in relation to
cost I don't know if our planning
Consultants sitting over there wants to
add any further comment but
um yeah
and developing the Heritage Provisions
for the proposed District plan we were
mindful of this and have tried to
provide a permissive framework where
it's Works associated with strengthening
um just to avoid their conflict
and I guess what flows from that is what
Morgan has at paragraph 4.4 of the
report which is on page 40 where you
talk about the proposed amendment is
this your proposed amendment
uh through the cheese it is it takes
influence from uh haranui District
Council uh being of a similar size
District population wise to the gore
Council it serves as a useful precedent
um
yeah
and and so you're wanting us to endorse
what you've got there under the hitting
3.4 are there any comments or feedback
that committee members want to give if I
may excuse me Mr chair through you
um because the building act stipulates
that this must be amended through the
special consultation procedure
yes so so your report says you want us
to endorse it so it can go to full
Council
is
um it does need an addition to it
and and the addition would read
something to the effect of the
provisions of the gore District plan
also apply and it may be necessary to
obtain a resource consent for any work
undertaken
through the chair Julie noted
so any other
queries coming from councilors please
no and so if we move to the
recommendation that is on page
41. the report be received and that it
endorses Amendment as set out
uh or sorry endorses an amendment to the
policy and that so it would be the
committee note
that a draft document that fulfills the
requirements will be presented to the
council and it's meeting on the 11th of
July is set out in paragraph
4.4 of the report with the addition that
I have given
so can I have a mover of all three of
those please
councilor Dixon secondary
counselor Reed all those in favor say
aye
carried
which moves us on to the gambling
economic and social review policy item 8
on pages 44-51
are there any comments or feedback that
committee members want to give to Morgan
on this
so it's really an update isn't it
councilor Reed just a comment um it's
quite good to see that drop off in the
machines that are actually functioning
and I guess
one of the big worries going forward is
the online gaming and some of the young
ones getting into the um
they've been loot year and also you've
obviously watched the same program but
also that channeling of what they're
actually watching
um that's actually leading them into
online gambling not only here but
overseas and there's no risk
restrictions or anything on that and
some of them are very very young that
are doing that that's out of our control
obviously and I see that the government
is actually looking at bringing in some
whatever
some sort of controls but how and what
they are who knows
any other feedback comments
councilor Dixon
um yes I I agree with
um councilor Reed and the other thing
that I'd add to that too is that it the
online gambling of people doesn't help
our community where some are not I'm not
encouraging gambling in Gore but what
I'm saying is there is spin-offs for the
community from from gambling and none of
that happens when people are doing this
online
do you think that we as a council have a
role Beyond just controlling the number
of machines
particularly through your community
well-being committee
very real possibility yes
so I'm wondering if the staff are able
to provide any comment in terms of if
the council
wanted to respond to what is clearly a
social issue
whatever news are open to us
any of the staff able to give us any
feedback on that or is that something we
need to consider when it comes up to um
full Council
because if we're looking at the full
well-beings that the council is
responsible for
um surely there's an issue here that we
should be exploring councilor Reid
so I'll just flagged there for the staff
to consider before it comes to the
council at the next meeting
and this uh
please
uh excuse me I'm just trying to cast my
mind back a couple of years when I
lasted a gambling policy but there is a
lot of legislation that surrounds us and
a lot of it has led from a national
approach obviously there's always a role
to support our communities in terms of
these issues but um I'm trying to think
that's
I guess that's effectively the the role
that you're looking at here and
considering through this policy is
whether or not how
how much restriction you want to put on
this policy as to whether you allow
limits on the number of gaming machines
or whether you allow new ones or whether
as you have a phase out so it's those
parts of the policies where you're
undertaking your role as local Council
to mitigate the social effects on our
communities and that's I think where we
see that role there's obviously other
spin-offs from that in terms of
um
Community impact and how we can support
people that are struggling with issues
such as gambling addiction and things
like that but there's that's I guess in
a nutshell the the purpose of this this
policy and the legislation
just through the first year yeah sorry
oh sorry yeah um yeah that's
absolutely correct Jason
um and I know that we do have a sinking
lid policy on the gambling machines
themselves and that's possibly why that
drop is quite as dramatic as it is thank
you Francis
were you going to say something yes um
councilor Reed we do have a sinking leg
policy but we also I think it includes a
non-relocation
so if a business was to close or
relocate they can't take
the machines with them to another site
so um yeah thank you
all right any other counselor Stringer
uh year three Mr chair
um can we ascertain from the values seen
through here how much that might be
gangs smurfing money through the machine
so what they do is they put money in of
course there's a percentage that comes
back they know they lose out but they're
actually giving cleaned money back do we
know that or is that a higher up the
food yeah yeah I think that's higher up
the food chain in terms of
a police issue
all right so we have a recommendation
the report be received can I have a
mover for that please
count councilor McKenzie
councilor Reed was moving her pin so I
took that as a yes yes spreading it
around so all those papers say I
against carried
item nine the climate change working
group update
um so there's some work happening behind
the scenes including
[Music]
um
a uh which is sitting on pages 52 to 74
an application being made to the
government for roughly 400 000 for
otago and Southland to work together to
look at some of these issues
I guess the question
um that might flow I'll come back to in
a moment but are any comments or
questions from counselors with regard to
that report
councilor Dixon
I do have a query as is the climate
change into Agency Group
is that going to be any cost to go
District Council because I see there's
500 and something thousand
provided from Council is that
environment Southland
through the chair from in terms of
Google District council's role it's not
a financial commitment being sought from
environment Southland it's a I guess a
commitment inclined to support that
through potentially some I guess input
through resourcing but it's not a
requirement to support it financially to
this application however the
impex of climate change are certainly
going to be something this Council needs
to look at in terms of this long-term
plan how we look to mitigate some of
those effects and I guess that's one of
the reasons for this application is to
look at there's a funding opportunity
there through central government to get
some funds to look at nature-based
solutions that may provide some sort of
mitigation relief for the gore district
and so environment Southland is just
seeking a
um
at this stage a support from the gore
District Council to put that application
in and and see if we can gather some
funding to to work on that enlighten me
please as to what nature-based solutions
for flood mitigation include
what are we talking about
um I can't give you the full detail or
spectrum of nature-based solutions but I
mean it's
um it could be a number of different
factors so it could be looking at
um one that has been discussed in that
we have seen as
um it could be like Upstream
um
uh opportunities to
put water out over a a farmland or a an
area to reduce mitigation Downstream
um it could be a number of different
factors that could be utilized in term
and particularly with this application I
think is initially hitting is
um being able to create
um detailed modeling that looks at
different flows and where those
potential breaches in our flood
mitigation systems are currently and
then what the impact of those are
knowing that you know sort of through
the 2020 floods we had
2400 qmix I think and so and it was
knocking on the door of the gore Bridge
so we
um with the impact of climate change and
the increase in
intensity and high rainfall events it's
not a matter of if but when we get
enough to breach our stop Banks and so
at the moment we can only and going
forward we can only build stop being so
high so we need to look at other
opportunities to potentially deal with
some of the
increasing flows
to offset the potential impacts on our
highly highly higher populated areas and
so that's what environment Southlands
Keen to investigate
so I guess what that's pointing to how
to slow the water down or divert it
elsewhere so wetlands
spillover areas I guess slightly
flub-free area on the tiring
um
all right thank you any any other
questions arising
the um
on page so what you're wanting then uh
Jason from that is that um I guess we
just acknowledge the work that's
happening uh at the regional level here
and and wanting us to endorse and
recommend to council that that we be an
active participant in in the work that's
been done at page
um 65
which sets out that
um application that's being made if I
can just bring that up
um
it talks about developing climate
adaptation community of learning
any any understanding of what that means
I'll have to sorry through the chair um
I'd have to investigate that and come
back to you one um just Kevin I will put
on this application is that the window
for this to be developed was very small
um and so
the environment Southland has been
working with MFE to try and extend the
date and this application has been
changing so I will make sure that when
this goes to council further
consideration that the most recent
version of this application is is
available as well just to um to check
off that but I can provide some
commentary at the time to around just
any other pieces of the application that
might need
explanation and and there is no doubt
amongst all of us that are here both
elected representatives and everyone
else that the the river is our largest
risk in terms of natural hazards and and
very obvious at that and I'm sure the
committee fully endorse our involvement
in that has set our in the
recommendation so can I have a mover and
a secondary for the recommendations that
are on page 53 and we'll deal with them
all together
so councilor Reid is a mover counselor
Dixon seconder all those in favor please
say aye
aye against carried
that brings us to the end of the agenda
but just before we finish I just wanted
to note that last week government
announced some changes that it will be
making with regard to the planting of
Forestry and putting some control back
in the Hound hands of of council and we
look forward to receiving a report once
government has firmed up on that because
in this this part of the country we
recognize that the current regime and
the National Environmental standard is
not fit for purpose so just to highlight
something that will be coming up at a
future meeting
there being nothing else so close the
meeting thank you for attending for the
staff and and to